what is the importance of the holy spirit
okay when are we full of the holy spirit
and how do we feel the presence
of the holy spirit all right
what is the importance of the holy
spirit uh what's the third second one
what is the importance of the holy spirit
right there oh is it here okay importance
of the holy spirit number two when are we when
are we fail and how do we feel how do we okay
the holy spirit is absolutely essential go to
romans chapter 8. romans 8 we're talking about
the holy spirit romans 8. what is the importance
of the holy spirit when are we filled with the
holy spirit how do we know we're filled with the
holy spirit romans 8 let's read from verse one
the bible there's therefore now no condemnation
to them which are in christ jesus who walked not
after the flesh but after the spirit for the law
of the spirit of life in christ jesus hath made
me free from the law of sin and death for what
the law could not do in that it was weak through
the flesh god sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh and forcing condemned sin in the
flesh that the righteousness of the law might
be fulfilled in us who walk not after the flesh
but after the spirit for they that are of the
flesh do mind the things of the flesh they that
are of the spirit the things of the spirit for to
be carnally minded is death but to be spiritually
minded is life and peace because the carnal mind
is enmity against god for it is not subject to the
law of god neither indeed can be so that they
that are in the flesh cannot please god now
when you read thieves that are in the flesh cannot
please god what's the other side of that they that
are in the spirit are the only ones who please
god now read verse 9 but ye are not in the flesh
but in the spirit if so be that the spirit of
god dwell in you finish verse 9 now if any man
have not the spirit of christ he is none
of his the only way you can belong to god
is if the spirit of christ dwells in us go to
verse 14. for as many as are led by the spirit
of god they are the sons of god go to verse
16. what does verse 16 say the spirit itself
beareth witness with our spirit that we are the
children of god it is the presence of the spirit
in us that testifies to the fact that we are the
children of god now go to genesis chapter one
we'll read from verse one we answer the question
what is the importance of the holy spirit
genesis one reading from verse one the bible says
in the beginning god created the heaven and the
earth and the earth was without form and void and
darkness was upon the face of the deep now you
read the rest and the spirit of god moved upon
the face of the waters the first member of the
godhead mentioned by name in the bible is the holy
spirit now let us go to john 14 let's read for six
john 14 for six
i'm thankful for that question whoever sent
it is a fundamentally important question
what is the importance of the holy spirit
do you have john 14 6 what does that say
jesus said what i am the way the truth and
the life jesus said i am three things the way
the truth and the life let's go to first
john chapter five reading verse six
first john 5 verse 6.
have you found it not yet some are
used to looking first john 5 6.
do you have it now all right read with me what
does it say this is he that came by water and
blood even jesus christ not by water only but by
water and blood finish the verse and it is the
spirit that beareth witness come on because the
spirit is truth now what did we read about jesus
in john 14 6 he is truth and the spirit is truth
now if the spirit is what jesus is then that tells
you immediately there is an equality between jesus
and the spirit now let's go back to john 14 6
jesus says i am the way the truth and the
life let's go back to romans chapter eight
let's see if we can find out if the spirit is
life john romans eight reading from verse one
we're answering the question what
is the importance of the holy spirit
when you found romans 8 say amen there's
therefore now no condemnation to them which
are in christ jesus who walk not after the
flesh but after the spirit read with me now
for the law of the word spirit of life in christ
jesus have made me free from the law of sin of
death and so we have the spirit of life and jesus
says he is life so jesus says i am the truth the
bible says the holy spirit is the truth jesus says
i am the life the bible calls the holy spirit the
spirit of life jesus says i am the way now is the
spirit the way let's go to galatians chapter 5.
galatians 5 read verse 24
galatians 5 24. do you have that
read for me what does this say
nice a lot if you have the king james version
now verse 25. if we live in the spirit let
us also walk in the spirit read verse 16.
say that again
walk in the spirit you shall not fulfill the
last of the flesh to walk in the spirit means
that the spirit is the way so jesus is the
way the spirit is the way jesus is the life
the spirit is the life jesus is truth the
spirit is truth go to john 3. john chapter 3
let's read from verse eight
john three reading verse eight where you found
it say amen okay let my brother find it john 3
verse 8. now this is a very important verse
giving us information about the holy spirit
are you ready the wind bloweth where it
listeth and now here is the sound thereof
but can't not tell whence it cometh or whether it
goes finish the verse so is everyone that is born
of the spirit what is jesus referring to when he
says born of the spirit the new birth conversion
and who what agent carries out conversion the
holy spirit jesus says so is everyone that is born
of the spirit why did i have you read that verse
only a divine being can bring about conversion
you didn't hear what i said the holy spirit
must be a divine being if he is the one
that brings about conversion because conversion is
salvation here's what the bible says in isaiah 45
verse 22 go there with me isaiah 45 verse 22 and
i'm going to take a long time on this question
because it is so important and god bless whoever
sent that question isaiah 45 we read verse 22.
isaac is called the gospel prophet when you
found it say amen read with me what does this say
look unto me and be saved all the ends of the
earth keep reading for i am god and there is
none else now i want you to think listen again
i'll say the first you listen look unto me
and be what saved all the ends of the earth
for i am god and there is none else what is
god trying to say when he says there's none else
there's no one else listen to the verse listen
to the verse look unto me and what so what's this
what's the heart and soul of that verse salvation
now the verse ends for i am god and there is
none else what is god saying in that verse
no one else can save but god are you with me go
to verse 18. are you ready read with me for thus
saith the lord that created the heavens god
himself that formed the earth and made it
he has established it he created it not in vain
he formed it to be inhabited now notice how the
verse ends but before we read the end of the verse
give me one word describing what we've read so far
listen to the verse listen microscopically
thus saith the lord that created the heavens
god himself that formed the earth and made it
he has established it he created another vein
he formed it to be inhabited give me one word
that describes what we just read creation
think now listen to how the verse
ends for i am the lord and there is
none else what is he saying there
is no one else who can create
so in verse 18 only god can create
in verse 22 only god can save
but jesus tells us in john 3 8 we are converted by
the power of the holy spirit then the holy spirit
must be defined go to isaiah 46
read verse 9 and verse 10 we're answering
the question what is the importance of the
holy spirit isaiah 46 9-10 are you
ready read with me remember the word
former remember what of all i am god and there is
none else i am god and there's none like me stop
why is god saying i am god there's none else read
verse 10 declaring the end from the beginning and
from ancient times the things that are not yet
done stop what is god saying he alone can do
come on declaring the end
from the beginning what's that
he alone knows the beginning from the end now keep
this in mind we've discovered only god can save
only god can create only god knows the
beginning and the end go to psalm 104
psalm 104 we discover the holy
ghost transforms us he saves
do you have psalm 104 read verse
29 the first part carefully
read verse 30 thou send this forth thy spirit they
are created the spirit is involved in creation
god creates the spirit creates god saves the
spirit says god knows the end from the beginning
let's find out if the holy ghost knows the end
from the beginning go to first peter chapter 1.
first peter 1
when i tell you read with me i can hardly hear you
maybe it's because you have 200 different versions
but if you have mine please read i love
to hear the church reading first peter 1
reading from verse 10 read might concentrate
as you read concentrate of with salvation
the prophets have inquired and searched diligently
who prophesied of a grace that shall come unto you
now read carefully searching what a what manner
of time the spirit of christ which was in them
did signified when it testified beforehand the
sufferings of christ and the glory that should
be revealed now the bible says the old testament
prophets were led by the spirit of christ
and they spoke of things that hadn't
happened for hundreds of years now
look at verse 11 again read that verse again read
with me what does it say searching what and what
manner of time the spirit of christ which was in
them did signify or tell them when it testified
the sufferings of christ and the glory that
should follow okay now how long of a span
is that look at the prophets question for
you who is the first prophet in the bible
enoch enoch now put your thinking caps on
where do we read about enoch's prophecy in jude
let's go to jude the book just before revelation
we're still answering the question what is the
importance of the holy spirit and i want you
to understand the holy spirit is a divine being
jude reading from verse 14
when you found that say amen i
assume you still looking for jude
jude by the way was the half-brother of
christ christ had another half-brother
who wrote the book of the bible what
was his name james do you have jude 14
read with me and enoch also the seven from adam
prophesied of this saying behold the lord cometh
with ten thousands of his saints to do what
to execute judgment now stop that's enough
enoch said the lord cometh with ten thousands
of his saints to execute judgment upon all now
what was enoch referring to when he said that
the lord cometh for ten thousand of his saints
not the first coming because at the first coming
he did not come to execute judgement jesus said
for god sent not his son into the world to
condemn the world but other words he might
be saved he did not come with ten thousand jude is
referring to enoch both the second and the third
now yes and the third because at
the third coming he's coming back
that's when he wakes the the sinful dead shows
them their lives and then destroys them now
it has been six notice the verse says
and enoch the seventh from adam meaning
or let me say this enoch and adam lived together
for many years that tells you how far back enoch
was prophesying are you following me six thousand
years since adam two uh four thousand six adam two
thousand six christ let's say that six thousand
maybe five thousand item live nine thirty okay
the millennium is how long a thousand so jude
enoch is prophesying something from the days of
adam that will happen over a thousand years beyond
our time he is giving the beginning to the end but
where did he get it the holy spirit first peter
1 verse 11 the spirit of christ which was in them
in all the prophets including jew and
enoch i'm trying to show you the holy ghost
could tell enoch what would happen thousands
of years beyond enoch's lifetime because the
holy spirit is a divine being we've
discovered the holy spirit can save
the holy spirit can create the holy
spirit knows the end from the beginning
the holy spirit is life the holy spirit is the
way the holy spirit is truth here's something
else for the holy spirit you need to understand
go to acts chapter 13 we'll read from verse one
acts 13 reading from verse 1.
very interesting passage the first four
verses of that chapter very significant
do you have acts 13 if you have my version
read from first one what does they say
now there was in the church that was at antioch
certain one apostles and preachers and teachers
as whom barnabas and simon which is called niger
and lucious of cyrene and manian which
have been brought up with herod the tetrax
and saul five men are mentioned prophets
and teachers now keep this in my next verse
as they did what minister to the lord and fast
it you keep up the reading now the holy ghost
said what did he say separate me barnabas and
saul for the work where unto i have called them
a lot of people say the holy ghost is not
a being he's just electricity or energy
energy cannot discriminate between personalities
the holy ghost looks at barbara barnabas
simon called niger lucius of cyrene monaean
and saul he looks at five and he said i want
barnabas and saul i have appointed a work for them
that's a personal being i'll tell
you something else about the holy
ghost go to first corinthians 2.
i am so happy for this question
i love to talk about the holy ghost
he is the invisible man in the godhead
first corinthians 2 we read 9 and 10. remember
think think as you read read microscopically
have you found first corinthians two reading
from verse nine familiar first read for me
what does this say but as it's written i have not
seen nor ear heard neither have entered into the
heart of man the things which god have prepared
for them that love him now read verse 10 come on
but god has revealed them to us cow by his
spirit keep reading for the spirit searches what
stop the spirit searches what all think now
we have to ask which all things keep reading
yea the deep things of god now the greek word for
search is to examine and understand profoundly to
have a profound understanding the bible says the
holy ghost knows everything god knows now you
tell me how can the holy ghost know everything
god knows unless the holy ghost is also divine
only a divine being can know everything another
divine being knows my brothers and sisters
there's a movement in the adventist church to
destroy the trinity teaching the holy ghost
the father the son three i individual
personalities but they're one in heart
and mission and go to john matthew chapter
3. now let's go to john 14. let me show you
again this time the holy ghost plus the father
and the son john 14 let's read from verse 16.
john 14 reading from verse 16. when you found
that say amen if you're still looking say amen
okay hurry up hurry up okay are you ready read
with me and i will pray the father now who is i
jesus who is the father to whom is jesus praying
to the father two beings are you following me
i will pray the father follow me now and
he shall give you what another comforter
who is there the comforter even the spirit
of truth stop here's jesus praying come on
to the father that the father might give what
the holy spirit three beings go to matthew 3.
matthew chapter 3
this is the baptism of jesus christ
have you found matthew 3 let's read from verse 16
what does it say and jesus when he was baptized
went up straight away out of
the water keep reading carefully
and lo the heavens were open unto him now
where is jesus coming out of the river jordan
and lord the heavens were opened unto him
and he saw what now jesus saw something
he didn't see himself he saw
something coming from where
out of heaven he saw the spirit of god
descending like a dove and lighting upon him
this is a separate entity so we have jesus coming
out he looks here comes the dove the holy spirit
can take any form he took the form of cloven
tongues of fire in acts chapter 2 verse 1 to
4. the holy ghost sits there in the form of a
dove now verse 17 and lo come on a voice from
where heaven stop where was jesus come on on the
earth where was the holy ghost on the earth where
did the voice come from in heaven we have jesus
coming out of the water he sees he's a witness
to an entity descending from heaven in the form
of a dove the bible says that's the holy ghost
sits on him then both of them hear a voice
from heaven which says this is my beloved son
in whom i am well pleased we have jesus we have
the holy spirit and we have the father my friends
there's the father the son the holy ghost now
there's much about them we don't understand
because a human being cannot fully
understand a divine being but the
bible gives us enough information to
believe there are three beings father
son holy ghost now they have different functions
are you following me let's go to john 14. john 14.
john 14. let's read verse 28 try to understand
how the members of the godhead function
john 14 reading verse 28
are you ready read with me nice and clear
you have heard how i said i go away and
come again unto you if he loved me
you would rejoice because i walk
i go into the father for my father come on
say it again my father now what did jesus mean
if they're all divine how could the father
be greater than the son let us go to john 13.
john 13 i think the verse is 16. you let
me know john 13 what does verse 16 say
verily verily i say unto you the servant
come on is not greater than his lord read
very carefully keep reading neither is he come
on read sent greater than he that sent him now
the verse has two people the one
who sent and the one who sends
you're looking at me as though i'm speaking a
foreign language do you see that in the verse
there are two people the one who sends
and the one who sent the verse says
verily verily i say unto you the servant is
not greater than his lord finish the verse
neither is he that is sent come on
read greater than he that sent him
what is christ saying the one who sends is
greater than the one who is sent go to john 15.
read verse 20. john 15 verse 20 what does that say
remember the word that i what's the word tell us
now this servant is not greater than his lord stop
now here's the father here's the son follow me
closely who sent whom the father sent the son
so with respect to authority who is greater
the father because jesus says the one who sins
is greater than the one who was sent but let's
look at the earthly analogy here's the servant
here's the master who is greater because the
master sends a servant but which one is more human
which one is more human they're the same
the master is as human as the
servant you look at me strangely
they're equally human but the master
has greater what authority here's jesus
here's the father they are fully divine but the
father has greater authority go to john 8 29
john 8 29
i know i know i am taking long on this question
but the glory ghost i believe is leading me
it is so significant john 8 29 listen to jesus
are you ready start reading and he that have sent
me stop you notice sent me there we have it there
it's all over john he that have sent me is with me
the father hath not left me alone finish the verse
for i do always those things that
please him question for you how long
has jesus been doing the
things that please the father
only when he came to the earth
from way back do you know creation was the work
that jesus did at the direction of the father
you didn't understand me jesus created
for the father he did what the father said
you read ephesians 3 verse 10 and to make all men
see what is the fellowship of the mystery which
from the beginning of the world have been hidden
god who created all things through jesus christ
yes christ was the means by which the father
created the same way christ is the means by which
the father gave himself i wanted you to see christ
has always obeyed the father's commands way back
before the world was made so when
he said i do always the things
he did not just mean on earth because when he
spoke to the pharisees in john 8 56 he said
before abraham was i am john 8 58 he
was telling the pharisees i go way back
the father is greater than the son
and the son has more authority than the holy ghost
let's look at that go to john 14. read verse 26.
john 14 and i may have to call an individual to
read for me to finally hear what you're saying
john 14 verse 26
are you there all right slow down okay doctor
april john 14 verse 26 as i try to slow down
are you ready read verse 26 or john 14
but the comforter which is the holy ghost
which the father shall send in my name stop that
verse says the father can send the holy ghost
in the name of jesus is that
clear yes or no go to john 15 26.
john 15 26 read for me now when the comforter is
come whom i will send unto you from the father
stop what do you notice who sends the comforter
in john 14 26 the father who sends the comforter
in john 15 26 jesus which means both jesus and
the father can give commands to the holy ghost
now when christ was on the earth in his
human form the holy ghost directed him
when christ went back to heaven it was christ
who ordered the holy ghost to bring all those
spiritual gifts and the gift of tongues the
holy ghost came at the direction of the son
now he's gone back he's on the right hand of
the father let me say it again as i slow down
when christ lived as a human being he was directed
by the holy spirit and he said the spirit of god
is upon me because he hath anointed me to preach
the gospel to the poor luke 4 18 but when he went
back assume his position now the holy ghost took
direction from him so here's what we have as far
as this substance they're all divine father
son holy ghost but as far as authority and
office you turn the fingers that way father son
holy ghost is that clear let me say it again
this is how they are the father is divine
the holy ghost is divine the son the son is
divine the holy ghost is divine when it comes
to responsibility and office and function
the farther highest then the son then the holy
ghost now here's the father here's the mother
here's the child are you with me which one is more
human they're all equally human but when it comes
to authority we have the father the mother the
child is that clear all right the holy spirit
is divine he is part of a family
of three now the most frightening
thing about the holy spirit let's read
it matthew 12 reading from verse 31
matthew 12 reading from verse 31 it's almost
what 40 minutes i've been on this question
but it's important matthew 12 reading verse 31
do you have it read for me nice and clear
let me understand the words you're saying
start reading wherefore say unto you uh-huh all
manner of sin aha very nice shall be forgiven unto
men keep reading but the blasphemy against the
holy shall not be forgiven unto men keep reading
and whosoever speaketh a word against the holy
uh-huh it shall appears the son of man it shall be
kiwi but whosoever speaketh against the
holy ghost it shall not be forgiven him
neither in this world neither in
the world to come wait a minute
the bible says you blaspheme
christ there's forgiveness
finish my words you blaspheme the holy ghost
there's no forgiveness now clearly they must
be equal in substance you understand you can
blaspheme jesus and there's forgiveness available
you blaspheme the holy ghost there's none which
means father son holy ghost the most sensitive
member of the godhead is the holy ghost so we
have to be very careful how we talk about him
and stop calling him energy and electricity and
sound waves whatever rubbish people call the holy
ghost the holy ghost is an intelligent
divine being and when he's offended
ah i don't want to be in your shoes all right
let me quiz you in john 14 6 jesus says three
things about himself without looking tell
me what the three things are here's the way
the truth we discover the holy
ghost is the the truth and the life
we discovered in isaiah 45 22 isaiah 45
18 isaiah 46 9-10 that only god can save
only god can create only god knows the end for the
beginning and we found out is the holy ghost who
brings about conversion the holy ghost was sent
he was involved in creation and the holy ghost
told the prophets what would happen thousands
of years before it happened what god can do
the holy ghost can do what the son can do the holy
ghost can do because all three are equally divine
but when the area of office and responsibility
fathers highest then son then holy spirit
the bible says if any man have not the spirit
of christ he's none of his now the second
question was how do we get the holy spirit
let's find three ways to get the holy spirit
the easy way let's go to matthew 11 matthew
7 4a let's read verse 11 of matthew 7.
let's read verse 11. i may not get to any other
question this is too important for me to take time
from this i just feel led to stay on this question
what book did i say matthew what chapter one first
just as clearly as you read just now read
now again start reading king james version
if he then being evil know how to give
good gifts unto your children stop
let me just digress even evil
people can make right decisions
ah you didn't hear what i said
listen to jesus if even being evil
know how to give good gifts so you
can't tell god well i was so bad
no no no even in your badness you have
some sense of what's good what's not good
if he then being evil know how to give good gifts
unto your children finish the verse how much more
read again how much more shall you
are which is in heaven come on give
now let's look at that verse carefully
good things is that singular or plural
plural jesus says your heavenly father knows
how to give what good things now many things
now luke will give us some explanation of what
matthew meant remember we did that this morning
with binding and losing luke
now gives us the same speech
but he changes the word slightly let's go
to luke 11 let's read verse 14. luke 11
14 matthew said the father knows how to give
good things many good things luke 11 14 13 13
what is that saying if ye then being evil
know how to give good gifts unto your children
how much more shall you walk heavenly father
give what the holy spirit to them that us ah
let's combine the two matthew says the father
knows how to give good things many good things
luke says the best of the lot is the holy
ghost ah you're not with me matthew says
many good things luke identifies one as the best
the holy spirit and then he tells us ask you want
the holy spirit what should you do ask now that's
one condition let's look at the second condition
acts chapter 5 let's read first 31 and 32. well
verse 32 of acts 5 how do i get the holy spirit
acts 5 32. are you ready are you sure
read with me and we are his witnesses of
these things and so is also whom the holy
ghost finished the verse whom god hath given
to them that obey him what's my favorite word
the bible gives us true conditions so far if
you want the holy ghost what should you do
ask what else should you do obey god
there's another one go to acts chapter 2.
acts chapter 2. have you found it now peter is
delivering the sermon on the day of pentecost
powerful sermon in verse 37
the bible says read with me
now when they heard this they were pricked
in their heart and said unto peter you're not
reading with me until the rest of the apostles men
and brethren finish the verse what should we do
read verse 38 clearly and microscopically read
did go ahead then peter said unto them what
repent and be baptized every one of you in the
name of jesus christ for the remission of sins
and ye shall receive come on the gift of
the holy ghost now we have three conditions
name them do you want the holy ghost number
one number two number three get baptized
are these my words or are you reading the bible
all right let me tell you something
else about the holy spirit
go to genesis chapter 6. genesis 6 we'll read from
first one our subject how to get the holy ghost
that's the subject of the sermon
uh god is good all right all the time
okay what book did i say genesis what chapter
six reading from what verse one read with me
please nice people and it came to pass when
men began to multiply on the face of the earth
and daughters were born unto them that
the sons of god saw the daughters of men
that they were fair and they took them wise
of all which they chose read carefully now
and the lord said what my spirit shall not always
strive with man for that he also is flesh yet his
day shall be 120 years the bible introduces
the holy ghost as the power that convicts us
it is the holy ghost that convicts you you're
wrong but you know what he uses to convict
the word and when you condense the
word you know what you get down to
if you take the word and boil it and boil
it until it comes down to a little thing
in the bottle in the bottom of that kettle
you know what that is the ten commandments
the entire bible teaches us
how to live up to god's law
so the holy ghost convicts us by the
application of the word to the heart
my spirit shall not always strive
with man my brothers and sisters
what we need more than anything else
in these last days is the spirit of god
go to john 16. let's read from verse 7.
we're looking at the holy ghost
again john 16 reading from verse 7.
it's 25 to 4. john 16 reading from verse 7
when you found it say amen those of you who
love jesus read nice and clear what does
it say nevertheless i tell you the truth
it is expedient for you that i go away for if i
go not away the comforter will not come unto you
but if i depart i will send him unto you now
read carefully and when he's come come on he will
reprove the world of sin of righteousness and of
judgment stop he will reprove or convict the world
of sin that's the problem of righteousness that's
the solution of judgment where the division will
be made between those who accepted righteousness
or those who lived in sin when he's come he'll
reprove the word of sin righteousness of judgment
okay of sin because they believe not on me
of righteousness because i go to my father
and you see me no more of judgment because
the prince of this world is judged now let's
read verse 13 how be it let's read 12 i have
yet many things to say unto you but you cannot
bear them now keep reading how be it when he
the spirit of truth is come you tell me the
rest he will guide you into all truth stop
never read the bible without
praying for the holy ghost
if you do do that you will guide yourself into
what error the holy ghost guides us into truth
he will guide you into all truth for he
shall not speak of himself that doesn't
mean he doesn't talk about him it means
he does not speak of his own authority
but whatsoever he shall hear whether from the son
or the father that shall he speak and he will show
you things to come if the holy ghost will show you
things to come no need to go to the witch doctor
nobody's listening to me the holy ghost will tell
you what you need to know he will show you things
to come save your money give it to the church not
the witch doctor read verse 14 for me now come
on verse 14 he shall do what glorify me for he
shall receive of mine and show it until you stop
he shall receive of mine what is the truth as it
is in jesus are the gifts he shall receive of mine
and show it unto you verse 15 all things
that the father hath are mine therefore said
i that he shall take of mine and it is the
holy ghost that decides who gets what gift
let's see that more clearly stated first
corinthians 12 let's read from verse 8.
how do we get the holy ghost we're
looking at what he does then we'll
get to how do we know we have the holy ghost
first corinthians 12 let's read from verse 8.
do you have first corinthians
12 reading from verse 8
some of you are doing very well with your reading
i'm so grateful read with me now what does it say
for to one is given by the spirit the word of
wisdom stop the spirit gives wisdom to another
the word of knowledge by the same spirit stop and
the list goes all the way to verse 10 to another
faith now it is the spirit that gives the gifts
but at the direction of christ and the father
the gifts in the church are given by the spirit
of god and he decides who gets which gift
okay how do we know we have the spirit let us go
to exodus 31. now reason with me please exodus 31.
you have exodus 31 verse 18.
and he gave unto moses when he had made an end of
communion with him upon mount sinai two tables of
testimony finish the verse tables of stone written
how with the finger of god keep this in mind
the law was written on the stone with
the finger of god let us go to luke 11.
luke 11 and i want you to reason based
on the verses i'm giving you we just read
the law is written with the finger of god
luke 11 20. now christ had cast out a demon
and he was accused of using the power of satan
and christ is defending himself now read verse
20 of luke 11 what does that say but if i with
the finger of god come on cast out devils know
thou the kingdom of god is come upon you jesus
says if i cast out devils by the finger of god
now what does that mean that's the
same finger that wrote the commandments
now this time let matthew explain luke
twice today we had luke explaining matthew
now listen to matthew explaining what luke meant
by the finger of god matthew 12 reading verse 28
matthew is dealing with the same incident but he
uses a different word and gives us light matthew
12 28 when you found it say amen read with me what
does it say but if i cast out devils how by the
spirit of god then the kingdom of god is common
to you luke says by the finger of god matthew
says by the spirit of god what is the spirit of
god the finger of god is a symbolic expression
for the spirit of god which means the spirit was
the being that wrote the commandments on the stone
but let's get more bible evidence go to second
corinthians 3 let's read verse 3. ii corinthians 3
verse 3. second corinthians 3 we want more
evidence that the spirit wrote the law on the
tables of stone he is the finger of god we've seen
that clearly but it's good to have more evidence
because some people just don't believe
quickly do you have second corinthians 3
verse 3 what does it say for as much as your
manifestly declared to be the epistles of christ
ministered by us we carefully now written not
within come on but with the spirit of the living
god keep reading not in tables of stone but in
fleshy tables of the heart the bible says the
holy spirit is the one who writes not only on the
tables of stone but on the tables of the heart
the same power that wrote the law on stone writes
the law on the heart somebody say amen same power
now you're asking me well yes the question
how do i know i have the holy spirit
give me one word when i obey god
when i obey god that's the overpowering
evidence that i have the spirit of god
i have that power that wrote it on stone and
that writes it on the heart so when god said i
will write my law in the hearts he does it by the
agency of the holy spirit if that's clear say amen
the number one proof that i am filled
with the spirit of god i obey god's law